Pendant longtemps, on croyait
que la propagation de la COVID
se faisait par les gouttelettes.
On sait maintenant que c'est
par aérosols. On en parle avec
une sommité en la matière :
Lydia Bourouiba, professeure
associée au prestigieux MIT
de Boston. Bonsoir.
- Bonsoir.
- Aérosol et omicron, c'est
un cocktail explosif. On le
constate avec les cas et les
hospitalisations qui explosent.
Est-ce que c'est le cas?
- La transmission par la voie
aérienne était là depuis le
début. Mais avec Omicron, il y a
des propriétés très effectives
pour atteindre une très rapide
transmission dans la population
à l'intérieur et même à
l'extérieur.
- Omicron se transmettrai
rapidement. Vous avez déjà
modélisé la transmission par
aérosols en 2010 avec le SRAS.
Il semble qu'on met beaucoup de
temps à comprendre la
transmission.
- La recherche sur la
transmission des maladies par
gouttelettes ou aérosols, cette
dichotomie en place, est basée
sur la science qui date du début
du siècle dernier, 1930.
Il y a une série d'études, entre
autres celle que nous avons
menée, qui ont clairement montré
que ce genre de classification
en deux route ne tient pas la
route. Il aurait fallu mettre à
jour les codes et les
réglementations sanitaires avant
cette pandémie. Pour pouvoir
incorporer la méthode de
précaution mais aussi la science
sur comment on exhale et émet
des gouttes d'une taille
continue entre 100 microns et de
petite taille facilement. Et
beaucoup de choses basées sur
cette notion de grosses gouttes
versus petite ne tient pas la
route.
- Plusieursl appelait à la
reconnaissance du rôle des
aérosols et d'autres disaient
qu'on n'a pas la preuve absolue.
Vous mentionnait le principe de
précaution. Au Canada, ce sera
le retour à l'école dans
plusieurs provinces demain.
Le retour à l'école en inquiète
plusieurs parce qu'il n'y a pas
nécessairement la bonne
ventilation, les codes ou les
balises dont vous avez parlé.
Vous avez déjà modélisé la
manière dont se transmet le
virus à l'intérieur d'une classe
avec des recommandations. On va
regarder cette courte vidéo
pendant que je vous pose la
question. On voit un point rouge
près de la porte d'entrée et un
autre près de la fenêtre. On
voit le courant d'air qui se
transmet. Quel est le risque ici
pour les personnes assises au
point rouge?
- C'était une illustration basée
sur les principes qui montrent
que si on ne porte pas de masque
qui empêche la propagation, au
bout d'un certain temps, ça se
propage partout dans la salle.
Si on veut augmenter la
ventilation, il faut le faire
mais il faut tenir compte de
certains principes de base.
Si on place les individus
proches de la sortie de l'air,
ces individus vont être exposés
de manière cumulative à
l'addition de tous les
pathogènes dans l'air puisqu'ils
seront au point de sortie si on
a un point d'entrée
qui est trop localisé, si on a
un individu malade en face :
frais, on aura une distribution
efficace des virus. On est en la
zone de respiration sur tout ce
qui est à l'arrière de cette
personne qui est en amont là où
l'air frais entre. Il y a
certains principes de base quand
on veut augmenter la ventilation
en classe auxquelles il faut
tenir compte.
Par exemple avec des
purificateurs d'air ou des
fenêtres.